well I'm joined Now by Imran Khan Imran
great to see you and it really is great
to see you
um how are you it's my first question
recovering peers I've I've got had three
bullets taken out from my right leg and
some strap Lord my left leg
so one of the bullets uh has uh
fractured my shin bone so that's that
would take a bit of time but I'm
recovering glad that it could have been
a lot worse
you know uh it was back in June that we
spoke and I asked you directly about how
you felt about the threat of
assassination you were aware of a plot
then to try and kill you and you said
when I entered politics I actually
conquered my fear of dying because I
came to stand against the entire status
quo I came to fight corruption my life
has had various threats over a period of
time and then you explain why you came
public about this but he said I have no
fear of dying
but when that moment happens when you
start to hear gunfire what on Earth was
that like for you
he
do you know uh
first it sounded like firecrackers
and then you know my right leg uh Buckle
under me because it was hit by these
bullets and initially it felt like a
burning sensation
and as I was falling there was another
there were two Shooters one was on the
left side
and he would have got me on the top body
but he was only 20 feet away so this uh
very brave person in the crowd went
after him and and went for the gun so
the gun went down uh you know this
pistol which was on automatic and when
it went down it hit my legs so when I
fell there was another shooter in front
and when he fired the bullets went over
me so as I was following these bullets
were going over me only you Imran could
be slightly smiling as you tell the
story I mean to me this sounds utterly
horrifying this is two people trying to
kill you
uh it was a plot look uh Bears I told
you when I spoke to you in June that
there was this plot uh why did they want
to kill me because when the whole
conspiracy to change my government and
uh and this regime change
they expected that the party would just
wither away or take years for it to
recover in fact what happened was that
unprecedented public reaction and you
had millions of people coming on the
streets the next day to protest against
the regime change so I think from then
onwards
what they expected was that my
popularity or my party would go down in
fact it went up that's when my life
became uh came in danger so there was a
first plot four people uh decided to
bump me off I I I found out because
remember I was head of the intelligence
agencies for three and a half years when
I was the Prime Minister
so I I named those people in a video and
announced that if anything happens to me
these four people would be exposed
they're powerful people
and then because of that it protected me
but then the party became even stronger
75 percent of all by-elections were
swept by my party against all the
parties put together so 11 parties on
one ticket and my party on and we we got
75 percent of the election so that's
when the second plot came in now this
plot was
to have me bumped off by a religious
fanatic and it would be that I had
committed blasphemy so this plot started
uh in September I and I found out again
how I find out is from within the
intelligence agencies because people
or by what is going on here so there is
they uh I found out I again went on the
media on public rallies two public
rallies on 24th of September and 7th of
October and said that they will they are
preparing the grounds
uh and it was a media first which
prepared the ground and I know who was
behind it and then they would have some
exactly what happened to be someone
would claim I'm a religious fanatic he's
offended my uh uh uh uh sensitivities
about religion and he would shoot me so
this was again it's on record the whole
script I I announced in a public two
public rallies uh and that's what
happened that's what they did Imran
notwithstanding the fact that you you
had these threats on your life to
actually go out and face big crowds week
in week out month in month out
you know I know you from your past as a
Fearless cricketer this is a whole
different world thinking that somebody
may be there wanting to take your life
how did you deal with that how did it
make you feel
there's when they impose this
a government of crooks and let me tell
you the whole country knows it's a
government of two families who've been
stealing money from this country who've
been in jail their books written on
their corruption I came into politics to
fight these two families so when they
brought them back through a conspiracy
and imposed them on us I decided that I
was not going to sit at home and that's
when I went out in the public and for
six months I was campaigning now during
these six months frequently I would get
this message that you know there's going
to be a Bomb Blast or your suicide
attacker or your life is a threat and so
I took a conscious decision do I accept
uh
these Crooks to rule over us just
because I'm my life is at threat or
should I believe as I believe in God as
a Muslim that life and death is it in
his hands so I I took a decision I said
look whatever happens I know that
there's these big guns are threatened
this uh uh what should I say mafias are
threatened if I and the more my party
got popular the more we sort of swept
the by-elections the more danger to my
life now when the first plot which I
mentioned earlier the second plot
was
um you know I I knew I as I said in a
public rally I spoke about it now
as I was falling when the bullets hit my
leg and I fell and these bullets went
over my head
and I then I felt my body because when I
was when the shooting stopped I felt
that aware and I felt my leg was hit I
was numb but I checked my top body then
I realized that the almighty had saved
me because there's no way I should have
been saved because there were two
Shooters a one very close 20 feet the
other one is right in the building in
front there's no way I should have
survived it but you know
that it reinforced my faith in in the
Almighty
I mean it wasn't astonishing Escape
you know by all you know if you look at
the footage you just assume that in that
scenario your chances of survival are
very small
Europe is this guy I mean the hero
they're two Heroes that uh that were
that saved me one was this this guy when
he saw him taking this pistol out
this guy immediately went for his hand
and you know when he uh when he tried to
grab the gun the gun went down and
that's how I I was saved because I would
have got all the bullets on my top body
so they went at my legs and then you
know uh this other guy also tried to he
had two magazines still so if this guy
hadn't intervened the guy would have
fixed two magazines then and kept
shooting and then you know when the
other guy hit hit us because it hit my
leg I collapsed so the bullets went over
my head I have in slow motion I felt and
I honestly even when I was lying there
with these three bullets I felt I'd been
saved
I mean truly remarkable the the first uh
guy who raced to your rescue who you can
see in the pictures pushing the
Shooter's Gun up
um and then the second guy you see
trying to run towards him then he as he
pushes him away he falls over and very
sadly it transpires he lost his life
this man really gave his life to save
you how do you feel about him
uh because I've met I this guy no he's
alive the one who saved me by grabbing
the gun and tried to grab the shooter
um he's alive yes I mean I mean
you know we I met the second man the
second one yeah the second
the the pairs the second one is even
more tragic he had come to this rally
with his two kids
and and so he with two kids there he
went for the gunman who shot him in the
face now that was really tragic I mean
that really touched not just me the
whole of the country because there was
this picture of him lying there and
these his kids sitting either side
trying to wake him up you know it was uh
I think that was uh probably
the most uh awful site I've seen so I
called his family I saw met his kids and
we have decided to take care of them for
the rest of their lives
yeah I mean I think that's that's a very
honorable thing to do remarkable courage
they showed
um you also Imran you have kids back
here in the UK and your ex-wife Jemima
was on Twitter saying how relieved they
all were to see that you'd survive this
but you know in those moments you must
also you're a father you know what were
your thoughts once you knew you'd
survived about your sons did you did you
want to speak to them quickly because
obviously they would they would hear
about it perhaps before you could even
talk to them
I did I well you know
I had I was driven from there or almost
took me two hours to get to the hospital
which I built you know which is the the
best for for me the best hospital in
Pakistan because three times I've been
treated there and I'm quite scared of
needles and stuff like that so I went to
the hospital two hours drive the moment
I got there then I spoke to my sons and
of course I spoke to my wife uh both of
them my wife actually was a remarkable
you know she was almost she was you know
the fact that I was saved she was quite
relieved but my boys were sort of quite
worried and I hope to see them soon
what did you say to them if you don't
mind me asking
you know the my oldest son always used
to worry because when I went entered
politics and I uh you know what I said
in your last program that you know I
came to fight for rule of law
a problem with Pakistan and most of the
developing world is that the their
mafias they're above law
and so there are two laws one for the
people and one these people can commit
any crime and are above law so I get
movement for justice is my party's name
men bringing these people under the law
so when you are tackling mafias you
always expect your life to be uh in
danger and that was 26 years ago I
always thought that uh you know
sometimes uh my my life would be a
danger but I took the decision that it's
better to you know fight for justice for
someone who's been privileged in my
country people have given me more love
and respect than probably any other
Pakistani so I always felt it was my
duty people like us could easy the easy
life but I always thought that people
like us have a responsibility to the
society so that's hence my boys knew
about it my older son especially he used
to always worry about it whenever I used
to take on some Mafia and my life would
be threat he would worry about it
I mean are they Keen for you now to stay
out of the public eye I've got three
sons in their 20s I would imagine if
something similar happened to me the
first thing they would want is an
assurance from their father that I
wouldn't be putting myself over the
parapet I know you and I know how
committed you are to this I'm sure you
want to continue but is that is that on
your mind your sons and how they feel
my sons when they were younger uh yeah
I'm talking about
my older son was very sensitive so when
I when they were about eight nine years
old my older son that's when he used to
worry a lot you know and he always
wanted me out of politics but you know I
you know I feel
that you know we human beings uh have a
responsibility to our society and this
is the spiritual way of life there are
two ways one is material yourself the
other is a spiritual and some 30 years
ago when I went on the spiritual path
that's the only reason I came into
politics because I realized I had a
responsibility
being so privileged in this country so
therefore uh you have to have faith and
faith is in God and the one verse in the
Quran that on
it's when the when the almighty decides
it's not one minute before one minute
after that's your time
so when I was lying on that uh you know
with these bullets I knew I had been
saved so it's so easy Iran because I've
sat in a cancer hospital I built this
hospital for five years my office was
there I saw healthy people coming in
going in six months or some being saved
so life and death I feel you know we
worry too much that we have control over
it we don't
it's an in almighty's hands
what is going to be your response in a
minute are you just going to continue
putting yourself out there going back on
protest marches continuing to fight your
cause will nothing change
well no the moment my leg heals I'm I'm
going to be out again but you know
people are so worried my in my country I
right now I've never had this feeling
before because they know that the guys
who missed this time will try again
public in Pakistan knows this because
these are powerful people
and they also are worried that if now if
Whenever there are elections my party is
going to sweep the elections all
opinions
polls surveys all these by-elections
they reflect that my party now is the
most popular party in Pakistan so
because of this threat and worried if I
win uh they they are going to try again
we all know it so I've doubled my
security at my house
I mean you are a remarkably phlegmatic
character Imran and again I go back to
when I watched you play cricket and he
faced the fastest Bowlers probably the
world has ever seen and you did it with
swashbuckling Panache and and audacity
and courage but it's one thing facing
fast Bowlers in a cricket match quite
another going back out after people have
tried to shoot you dead and know that
they may try again
uh were you getting this strength of
character from
Bears faith I have uh you know I never
really had faith in my life till much
later I had end of my cricketing career
and it's very clear there are two ways
of spending your life one is you know
where you're conscious
the spiritual life which is that there
is a purpose to existence and how how
much the almighty gives you the more
responsibility he puts on you so that's
one way and the other is living for
yourself which is very easy I mean even
from after Cricket I never had to work
after that I could easily live a very
comfortable life so it was a conscious
decision some 30 years ago that this is
it I have I must try and change my
society and the one one thing one
sentence rule of law it's what makes a
difference between a civilized society
and a Banana Republic and so one thing
that is keeping us back is we don't have
Justice here and you know it pays for
your information help me the ex-prime
minister
the head of the biggest party in
Pakistan my government is in control in
the biggest province in Punjab where
this attempt took place
do you know I could not get a case
registered against these three important
people and only because one of them was
this intelligence officer I couldn't do
it because they are so powerful that the
police would not register my case so
just imagine what a common man goes
through this in this country where he
comes against the powerful you're
helpless and this is what I've been my
struggle for 26 years and Will Go On
Till I till I'm alive do you have any
doubt Imran that this plot was conceived
and executed by the current government
I have absolutely no doubt who I know
the three people who did it one is this
intelligence of a Major General vessel
because remember I I repeat again for
three and a half years when I was a
prime minister the intelligence agencies
worked under me I know how they work so
I know how this whole whole plan this
the consequence sequence of events how
they planned it how can you how will you
be able to intelligence how will you be
able to prove it
the moment there is an investigation the
sequence of events how they first came
out with this tape which accused me of
blasphemy that was made by these
intelligence agencies then they handed
over to reporters who were attached to
them how do I know because when I was in
government I know how they worked and
then it went to the ruling party there
then information Minister that went on
TV then state-run TV ran a campaign
Howard insulted the sentiments of
religious people and it's all nonsense
it was all to eventually justify that
some religious fanatic had shot me so I
know the sequence events the two prime
minister and the uh the interior
Minister there is a they in broad
daylight they had 12 people massacred 60
bullet wounds were in a protest which
was called the Model Town Massacre who
can you trust
you're very passionate about who you
think uh ordered this and executed it
but who do you trust in Pakistan to
properly impartially investigate this
well
let me tell you that the institution of
the army people are extremely upset what
has happened
so it's not as if the whole institution
is involved you know this I believe that
this intelligence officer I know there
are two accomplice and remember the the
intelligence services are under the
prime minister so there's the Prime
Minister and the interior minister so
the only hope I have is that if the
Chief Justice of Pakistan if he asserts
himself if he takes if he now has this
inquiry conducted through the Supreme
Court you know gets the people involved
of repute already there's a case there's
a there was the best investigative
journalist of Pakistan arshad Sharif he
was my you know he was
talking about this regime change and he
was always
backing my point of view he was the
number one journalist he was hounded out
of Pakistan the same Intelligence
Officers were involved he was threatened
he left Pakistan for the way he went to
Kenya he was assassinated in Kenya this
so it so I know who's behind it and I
know that it's throughout the
institution of army that is behind us
and I know that the these two killers
the Prime Minister and the interior
minister they have a track record of
extrajudicial killing and as for the
shooters one of them we know was
arrested uh the second one that you
claim was shooting has not been arrested
what do you think happened to that
second shooter
I think the second shooter is at large
uh you know it's not just me I mean I
these bullets because this shooter was
on a left the bullets that were going
over my head and others and in fact the
eye witnesses who saw it him firing from
a building so we have no idea and the
police hasn't registered a case against
the other one they've only blamed this
so because this shooter
fits in with the with the narrative that
it was a religious fanatic by the way
he's not a religious fanatic because the
social media guys went to his his home
and and discovered this guy didn't even
pray so but he was a very professional
shooter you know he shot with this
automatic if you I have done pistol
shooting and if you shoot it on
automatic it's very difficult unless
you're used to it to control it because
it goes up but he had complete control
so he was a trained guy and the other
one I've we've all we you know we 100
sure that he was the one who was the
rail you know who would have been the if
I if I had if he missed me he would have
got me
there have been a lot of incidents
recently of
attempts and some were successful to to
kill politicians around the world we've
had two members of parliament murdered
in the UK in the last six years we just
saw the house speaker in America Nancy
Pelosi's husband hammered by a maniac
and lucky to have escaped you know there
is a kind of rising tide of violence
against politicians what what do you
make of that and what can we do around
the world to try and stop this
is you know the every uh every country
has different reasons for the lives of
politicians being in danger in our
country is is completely different to
what would be happening uh in the U.S or
or in Britain ours is very
straightforward we have Elite capture
there's a capture by a tiny Elite of our
resources this country
and they just do not they're threatened
by someone like me who has came in as an
outsider and certainly now has the
biggest party in Pakistan a political
party which is certain to win the
elections so that's where my threat
comes from and the problem is you know
the the people who are raised up against
me are extremely threatened and they are
and uh and as I said I think they'll try
again
one of the other major issues right now
is Free Speech we've got Elon Musk has
bought Twitter and is determined as he
says to bring back Free Speech we've
also seen in August uh the author Salman
Rusty attacked on stage and nearly
murdered suffered horrific injuries
obviously that is a controversial
subject in Pakistan Salman Rushdie and
his book Satanic Verses what is your
reaction to what happened to Salmon
Rushdie
I've already given my reaction up as as
you quite rightly have pointed out it
has a uh especially in our country it's
extremely controversial
I mean is it so controversial you don't
want to say anything
uh you know I have enough issues right
now to uh
to deal with rather than uh you know
have
other issues on my head
I mean I I and I understand it but there
were a lot of people who obviously would
have felt that Free Speech should mean
free speech that will happen to Salmon
Rushdie was a consequence of a a fat
while being put on him and somebody then
executing that fatwa
uh because look you know I've commented
on that issue and uh
there was a big backlash because people
don't understand this and I'm talking
about where I'm sitting right now so
where you are from I understand your
point of view but where I am uh you know
it is just going to cause as it did
before when when I commented on it so uh
let me just pass on this
I mean just as a final observation you
mean that it would put your life in even
more Danger should you continue to
comment on it
look I have enough challenges already
I understand
let me ask you about the U.S midterm
elections which have just taken place uh
unusually and well I think surprisingly
the Democrats and Joe Biden didn't get
the heavy losses that they were
anticipating and that everybody else was
anticipating what does that tell you
about the state of American politics
what is your view now of the Biden
Administration I know that you blame
them for what happened to you earlier
this year do you hope to have a better
relationship with them going forward
look there's yellow
who would not want to have good
relationship with the United States it's
a superpower and from Pakistan's point
of view uh we export the highest exports
out to the US and the most powerful and
the richest Pakistani expatriate
Community are the Pakistani American
in the U.S so
we you know it's Unthinkable that you
would not want to have good relationship
with the US there's only one issue I
have you know Pakistan and U.S
relationship has been like uh
transactional Master Slave relationship
when Pakistan is needed you know we
serve a purpose and then and we degrade
ourselves by the way I don't blame the
US that much I think we allow ourselves
to be used like a tissue paper and it's
humiliating as a Pakistani that you know
we were we got independence the same
time as India India has
you know a very dignified relationship
with the U.S you know the every country
wants to protect its interests India
stands for its interests but what
Pakistan has done is we've been like
slaves we've been used like for instance
the war on terror Pakistan had nothing
to do with the with 9 11. we were the
the head of the uh our state claimed
that they were forced into this war by
the U.S because the U.S would bomb us
into stone age we ended up losing 80 000
pakistanis in a war that had nothing to
do with us so that's what I object to I
want a relationship like India has with
the US
we have in the UK now the first uh prime
minister who's come from an Asian
background Indian Heritage Rishi sunak
uh you spent a lot of time in the UK
were you were you surprised by that were
you pleasantly surprised that we finally
gone for a non-white prime minister
I'm uh I I am surprised because you know
my what I had you know and I remember I
went there as an 18 year old and then
there were these skinheads around and
they would beat up any one Asian they
would beat them up and call them pakis
so I saw that uh you know the beginning
and racism was very obvious at that time
as a cricketer as a young cricketer I
used to see feel racism and county
cricket but when I became faster in a
fast bowler then of course if there was
racism it was behind my back it wasn't
on the cricket field but in the in the
beginning I were there would be racist
comments on right on your face but I saw
the change take place but I must confess
I never thought that a day would come
and Britain would be ready for an Indian
origin prime minister and I think it's
very positive
you know he's a massive Cricket fan he
goes and has Nets at the oval
um he and I said are you a defensive
bats when he went absolutely not front
foot very much in the Imran Khan
category of batsman by the sound of it
um are you comforted that we have a
leader in this country who's a cricket
fan I always think they're on a
different level of human being Superior
uh uh look it's uh Britain I mean
whoever becomes the prime minister right
now you know he has to have the ability
to take pressure because it's going
through a I feel probably one of the
I mean ever since I've uh you know been
in touch with Britain 70s there were
these Gold Miner strikes and and so on
strikes but since then I think this is
probably the toughest time the country
is going through so it's not going to be
easy he needs to be
it'll be a baptism of fire for uh yeah
do you know have you met him
no no I've never met him would you like
to
yes one day uh yes I would
I want to end on a positive note Imran
it's been a riveting interview as always
with you but particularly given what
happened to you
um the T20 World Cup literally moments
before I sat down for this interview
Pakistan had a fantastic win over New
Zealand and have roared into the T20
final well they may end up playing
England
a repeat of 92 World Cup because we beat
New Zealand in the semi-finals and then
we played England in the final uh yes
it's a country celebrating right now
it's a it's as you say it's not been
easy uh probably not even in England but
it's not been easy here and this win has
given all of us a great boost so we're
all looking forward to the final
and you've got this young Superstar Baba
who is absolutely thrilling to watch who
led the way today
you see but I you know I frankly I
haven't had much time to watch cricket
but when I was the when I was the Prime
Minister I did uh because my Cricket was
at the time going through a bad time
so I watched simply I've only watched
him play twice you know proper innings
and I immediately asked uh the head of a
Cricket Board you must make him the
captain because he is a genuine world
class I think he's an exceptional player
I haven't seen a player with such
versatility you know but such a correct
technique such stroke play and
temperament I mean he has all the
qualities I think he he could he could
go anywhere from here but him as the
captain makes a lot of sense because you
want your captain to be
a world-class cricketer so that he
commands respect and I think our team
looks good I'm I think we we might just
win the final well let's not be too nice
to hear him I'm sorry but our boys are
coming for you and just to remind you we
also recently won another world cup so
we've got a bit of a bit of trophy in
the cabinet
well it'll be very interesting right
we're all looking forward to watching it
are they I whether it's India Pakistan
or Pakistan England it's going to be a
fantastic final Imran it's fantastic to
see you I really I started that way and
I really mean it when I first heard
about what had happened you always fear
the absolute worst in my heart sunk
particularly given the conversation we'd
had just a few months ago so it's great
to see you alive and well and recovering
well and I wish you all the very best
and thank you very much indeed for
joining me
thank you peers it was a pleasure